[Music]
welcome to JK news today we were talking
about first of all this is from reddit
relationship advice I mean it's a great
your reddit check it out
woo we're at a table together yes and
this is from reddit you throw away just
you guys just you guys not not that
simple not this people yes always throw
away super nanny says I am a nanny for a
very wealthy and powerful couple wealthy
and powerful okay we don't know I have
stomach Ross evidence that he's cheating
on her with prostitutes in foreign
countries should I tell her I mean
that's how stereotypically knows she
knows a powerful couple and she's he
isn't that like every movie or every
Korean drives like every drama every
soap opera that's such a good question
cuz if I was working there I wouldn't
say she nah I want my job war doc right
make hella money or she could pull Kevin
Hart but then what if you blackmail
powerful people aren't you afraid of
dying you're dead she's a living nanny
while she finishes up school Friday she
wasn't on the computer and the shared
home office to check the younger boys
schoolwork and as soon as she turned it
on the printer started spitting out
papers she grabbed the pages to see if
she should save them or throw them away
and they were screenshot pronounced from
a forum where men were talking about the
best places to find prostitutes on a
certain Island where the father will be
taking a solo vacation in a few months
perhaps coincidentally I added that he
takes these vacations on his own twice a
year always to someplace exotic with the
beach we live in the Midwest that's in
parentheses he likes hot tropical
weather my the mother explained to me
once that her schedule isn't as flexible
as his and she doesn't require as much
rec or in our relaxation as he does and
he likes to see more than she does they
always take at least two big
international family vacations every
year and he will occasionally drop off
for a romantic getaway he and she will
occasionally do a romantic getaway it's
nice to be rich I'm certain she does not
know he's visiting prostitutes she's
deeply religious the mother the daughter
of missionaries and the mother of his
guests why he wants to see prostitutes
exactly she doesn't suck his days also
this is my favorite part an elder in
their church
just Sunday school she's absolutely
gorgeous he's going to the island to
stop prostitution maybe he's hiring
prostitution to talk to you have a one
on one moment with him and pray together
I convert them my wonder riding him he's
like have you have you met Jesus hey
give him a head hurt al ron Hubbard so
yes she says yeah he says that she would
be oh wait she's absolutely gorgeous
takes pride in staying fit and
maintaining her looks yeah but I has
nothing to do with anything if she
doesn't suck his dick yeah true so true
she'll be humiliated to know he was
doing this and I know she'd be deeply
betrayed she wants told me her first
husband cheated on her and she feels
blessed to be married not to a man of
such excellent character that's where it
gets I thought it was arranged before
she had a second she's our second
husband and he's cheating again she has
a type they both treat me like family
they're both that slim pants she
obviously doesn't treat them like family
cuz he's [ __ ] Narconon read it but
okay what do you really think oh man if
I was the neck yeah oh man I thought
somewhere in there she was gonna be like
oh by the way while he [ __ ] me last
night he told me his name oh Jesus he
[ __ ] me last night and then he told me
everything yeah [ __ ] I can't see [ __ ]
because I'm not family nor my friend
like I'm hired help feels like she's
burdened with guilt because she has to
face this woman it's just that woman
woman like secret well they both see you
as family and then you know that they
cheated so you're like what the [ __ ] do
I do do I tell the person unless she
knows what her past husband did and how
that affected her yeah exactly
women the women bond so women women like
you know it's like the bro code the lady
code right yeah but she's gonna tear
apart this family well she's not gonna
tear apart a family I'm bailing the tear
but he doesn't know well what if she's
gonna free the the wife now she doesn't
know that she knows I don't know be sure
up ssin is now right now she's
she should send anonymous letter or
[Music]
anonymous yeah he gets the letter and
[ __ ] rips it up and throws it away
but then if it's anonymous how does she
give the evidence anonymous without
giving herself yeah it might be someone
trying to tear him apart but they don't
have to give the evidence just say hey I
know prostitute and he pays for me and
nothing happens then you could do
somebody else later that's not bad or
what about V right there finding a new
job and running away from all of this
sounds like a dope job though
I wouldn't want to risk I want to work
for richer people like that that are
nice and they treat you like family
I know I'll just be eating oatmeal there
and be like you [ __ ] so turbulent you
owe me all your working
oh no but they're rich though so he
works for them we'll have breakfast
together and then I'll start cleaning I
don't think they're gonna let you
something cable the house is so big then
one no but they treat him like family
yeah dang that's rough he let me jack
off in one of the rooms oh wow goddamn
everywhere you go no matter the
profession you're always check enough
yep
dude so I had friends years ago yeah and
the the husband was cheating on the wife
and I will never forget how this felt
too cuz he used to joke about it all the
time with her in the room and I was like
okay he's just doing bits and stuff and
then he's like yeah I'm gonna get chicks
from Craigslist you mind if I bring her
over and [ __ ] her in your house and I
was a high high yeah sure that's great
and then one day he brings in front of
his wife no she didn't know oh so you
thought he was joking he was doing bits
with all of us in front of his wife he's
like doing bits like about how he's
cheating on his wife in front of his own
wife so it was the truth coming out yes
but as a joke as a joke
he's totally inoculating himself racism
later and then he would bring these
chicks he's like I told at order tasty
want to be a part of my prank and he
breathes his girl over hey I
[ __ ]
never seen more innocent to me because I
was around the wife and she's a little
bit yucking it up too
so really my god so then one day he
actually brings a chick over to my
apartment
every yeah and he's [ __ ] the chicken
the other room and I know his wife and I
know his wife she's way stronger so he
brought the girlfriend you said cool
joke bro
go ahead well I just thought he was
kidding oh [ __ ] I thought that he was
just show up with his wife like they
always do cuz he's to come over like
every week and then he actually showed
up and he's like yo can you give ed
renown as a teacher what and he's like
yeah no no no just like closed the doors
fine
and then he went into my buddy's room
and then they [ __ ] in his room on his
mattress right and then I heard it all
happen you were an accessory to this I
was accessory completely oh my [ __ ]
another woman in my place like this is
crazy and I know what the [ __ ] to do so
then I just completely stop talking
about the time mmm
yeah did you say wait can i [ __ ] - oh my
god that's not my style I wouldn't do it
either but I would just say what what
did you do it's like hey what what are
you doing hey are you done yet I want to
turn and then you sit down with a clear
mind and you go yeah I don't think you
should have done damage after you blow
me I want to save you from this
institution but I need you suck my dick
first okay can I interview you will
happen after I had to slowly peel myself
away from them in a way that seemed not
too crazy because they're both my
friends and so it's like it's one of
those things where unfortunately I
wasn't just friends with the guy I was
friends with both and so I was like how
do I [ __ ] that's right these waters
while being a good friend and a good
friend will just tell the wife what the
[ __ ] is up right so I I was a bad friend
and I just shut the [ __ ] up and got
pieced out and just drop the mic and
more yeah what would you do differently
now nothing because it's not it
ultimately looking back his wife could
have been pissed at me just for
shattering her world yeah that's true
and and yeah it's not her but it's not
your business it's not my job to know
what's the truth just wasn't that it was
my sister I'd [ __ ] immediately
destroy this whole thing and I'd [ __ ]
told the truth but this was a little
different than that and I felt loyal to
both of them and you don't know maybe it
maybe it was open and you just didn't
know it wasn't
I know okay okay I have a friend who's a
he's a filmmaker and he swore that in
order for him to accurately study the
characters in the underworld he had to
go to the brothels ha ha ha so his
girlfriend knew but he was going there
to to interview them and he bought the
time to interview them and talk to them
and all that stuff
and it was it was he went to bars and he
went to these different types of places
where you can buy the time of a hostess
and sometimes it's a spa sometimes it's
like you're in there and how much
research did he do lots and lots of
that's like a perfect movie or do you
join him on these I went to one bar
where he talked to a set of twins it was
an interesting bar because in between
his drinks he would make out with both
of them and hold them which I thought
was a very weird bar and you're just
sitting there watching and watching I
had my own girl of my own and we were
having a conversation but and then he
was like touch her he goes yeah he's
like they're [ __ ] yeah just touch her
it was fine yeah and I'm like and he was
explaining to me the whole thing like
yeah so yeah and you sitting there
spitting game to them like YouTube
you're gonna be a star and I literally
saw this whole [ __ ] casting couch
producer [ __ ] go down in front of my
eyes and I was like is this [ __ ] for
real and the girls bought it they were
like really and then they started like
looking like yeah we're like you could
get both of us like we're twins and [ __ ]
and I'm just like this is [ __ ] Nelson
what would you do what would you do but
it's like a porno I know what would you
do did you write the movie you didn't
tell his chick did you he didn't write
the movie studying it I bet you till
this day you still studying
you didn't tell his chick did you know
see so what would you do there was so
much that just happened in that story I
don't even know where I am in that story
now what about my story between our
stories what would you do I feel I feel
like let me think if I was in your
situation that was a lot to handle it's
all crazy right yeah
and my way we were both raised Catholic
good boys were good boys I was devoutly
religious and I was not but I can play
along with this okay
by the way were both raised good boys
yes I was raised a good boy I was a good
boy goodness I wasn't a good it was good
true you killed him you wanna mafia that
was medium good I don't and you said
you're equally friends with both of them
huh big time I love them both and
connected with them both I feel like I
would have to speak with the guy like I
would have to tell tell about how I feel
at least being that I at this point you
feel like an accessory so you're having
your own emotional like baggage from
this and you left with it and you didn't
affect them at all but now you you have
this own baggage that apparently you
still carry you right I feel very good
we clear the air with him and then see
where this is a weird man I thought it
was a joke
apparently it's not a joke how old are
you 27 I was 23 you know I had you know
I was young I was young boy I I don't
know man I just thought it was hilarious
because I just couldn't believe how
[ __ ] bold and that's probably what
you thought like how [ __ ] bull I
couldn't believe it I was just shocked
and as the bar girl was in between my
legs and holding me the whole time I was
sitting on a stool like this with my
legs spread she came up like this she
she [ __ ] held me and I'm sitting here
with the [ __ ] Tony son I'm here I'm
drinking like this
I'm not alcoholic yeah and he goes go
ahead and touch her and I was like what
this is that kind of bar well you told
me to and my hand went on this way and
the whole thing I'm like what were you
touching her butt so she's hugging she's
facing me I'm on the stool she's on like
this way just cuz it was custom for that
bar and he's contemplating life though
this feels wrong yeah and I'm the whole
time I can't even focus on how nice the
ass is because I'm just drinking this
drink and I'm going like you [ __ ]
you're all judging them as you're
holding her because of how guilty is no
and how the [ __ ] did he have two twins
yeah
[Music]
[Music]